la plaza de la independencia cientos de
personas acudieron a celebrar el anuncio
de la salida de las tropas francesas que
llevan nueve años en malibú
estamos felices la soberanía pertenece
al pueblo aconsejo a emanuel macrón que
escuche este mensaje antes de que sea
demasiado tarde
una salida solicitada aquí por los
manifestantes que denuncian el
empantanamiento de la operación barkan y
la política exterior de francia en malí
la semana anterior las autoridades de
transición habían pedido la retirada
inmediata de las fuerzas de baján y
tacuba una retirada que celebran aquí
quienes dan la bienvenida a los nuevos
socios del ejército maliense es gracias
a rusia que también vino están allí
desde ya hace 6 o 7 meses sólo están
formando a nuestras fuerzas armadas y
francia lleva más de 9 años allí pero
nada ha cambiado una asociación con
rusia que preocupa a algunos en la
oposición es soluble militaire en el
plano militar el ejército maliense con
quién va a estar hoy el presidente ruso
dijo el estado ruso no está involucrado
así que se trata de una empresa privada
que viene por sus intereses no por otra
cosa no van a morir por mali y el día
que no les paguemos será cuando nos
abandonen en pleno vuelo
considerado un playboy a pesar del
aumento de los efectivos del ejército
maliense como anunciaron las autoridades
de transición hace unos días murieron
ocho soldados mientras realizaban una
operación en el norte en la llamada zona
de las tres fronteras una zona donde
decenas de civiles han sido ejecutados
recientemente por el estado islámico en
el gran zar en este inmenso territorio
que actualmente escapa el control del
estado la población reclama la creación
de un ejército nacional rey constituido
tal y como se prevé en el acuerdo de paz
de argel